greetings greetings bill nighy here
today we're going to do some science
support our first question comes from
Destiny Dolan no serious question what
makes people think global warming isn't
a real thing like it's February and at
70 degrees outside upside down smiley
emoji so I'm thinking now that it's
cognitive dissonance this is a real
effect where people have a certain
worldview they're confronted with
evidence which conflicts with the
worldview so they have dissonance
conflict in their minds what's generally
done instead of changing your worldview
which you may have held your entire life
you dismiss the evidence and along with
that you dismiss the authorities that
may have provided the evidence bird TV
asks if we can clone extinct species
should we I think it'd be cool what
we're all talking about is like a woolly
mammoth hi Steve
all right bill it's my woolly mammoth
impression this one would be named Steve
anyway I think it'd be cool but it's not
up to me
carry on do you know how long Earth has
existed this is from ISA Nissan and I
would say yeah 4.6 billion years rocky
on line I have a doubt related to
evolution theory if we evolved from
monkeys then why are there still monkeys
haha that's brilliant
you're the first guy to ever wonder this
we did not descend from monkeys monkeys
and we have a common ancestor so you may
have seen this picture this famous
arrangement this isn't really accurate
it wasn't just one to the other to the
other as we say the the family tree of
hominids like you and me and even my old
boss haha it's not just a straight line
of one organism leading to another it's
a bush as we say so there's many many
branches and you and I ended up on one
of them and so we did not descend for
monkeys monkeys and us have a common
ancestor and you can prove it Anthony
Arjun Arjun Arjun asks what makes a
planet a planet you gotta have enough
gravity to be a ball and right now you
got to have enough influence to clear
out your orbit from
stuff other debris stand with Rand
rights can alternative energy
effectively replace fossil fuels
absolutely yes burning coal is the worst
thing we can be doing so I encourage you
to check out the solutions project.org
they have done an analysis of not only
the United States as electricity needs
but 130 other countries around the world
and we could power the whole place right
now if we just decided to do it with
wind solar energy some tidal energy some
geothermal energy we could run the whole
place wouldn't shut down existing
nuclear plants but it's really hard to
build a new nuclear plant because nobody
wants them around running to asks a
double rainbow I saw a couple months ago
what causes double rainbow opposed to a
normal rainbow well one could make an
argument a sense there's always a double
rainbow it's just the second one is much
fainter it doesn't it's not as bright so
the background has to be the sky has to
be dark enough for you to see it
generally our camp asked why is this guy
glue why can't it be green careful what
you wish for air molecules are spaced in
such a way that when waves of light pass
between them they are scattered as we
increase the greenhouse gases in the
Earth's atmosphere people have
speculated that the scattering will
change the molecules that are doing the
scattering will be so abundant that the
sky will no longer be blue it's not good
carry on our camp
vexy drawing magnets how do they work
their magic
no what happens in certain materials the
strongest one most common one the one we
all know and love is iron and these are
steel and steel is almost entirely iron
just a little bit of carbon there's what
they call a virtual current where the
electric electrons are moving from atom
to atom and this produces this magnetic
field and this tendency is so strong
that magnets stay magnetic for centuries
chocolate chip asked what is the fourth
dimension is it smell fourth dimension
is time this is not rocket surgery
fourth dimension is time X Y Z time lil
poundcake asks can artificial
intelligence take over the earth yes yes
what do you think
no people make artificial intelligence
are we gonna make a machine that
produces electricity in a way that we
can't control that takes over for us
really who is gonna build that machine
how long do you genuinely believe the
human race is existed on earth about a
hundred thousand years Jerry buck what
is dark matter it's not clear but it has
apparently an influence like gravity and
there's more of it than there is regular
matter that you and I are familiar with
Gerogia person people say that cell
phones
I think it's might give off radiation to
the brain turns out people get brain
tumors all the time people talk on cell
phone way way more of the time they have
done studies trying to connect cell
phones and brain tumors there is no
connection carry on farad OMSI how safe
is acupuncture I knew people believed in
acupuncture there's no value to it but
if you think it works and it makes you
feel better carry on will horseradish
and rib O's you leak through you when
you after you get acupuncture
I don't know run a test try it Brianna
Rey they say avocados are good fat but
how much avocado can you eat before it
becomes bad fat you can eat a million
avocados what do you think for crying
out loud there's calories and avocados
just there's also some unsaturated fat
avocados are great I recommend an
avocado with a poached egg that is
that's living mates I wonder what the
world would be like after a nuclear war
it would suck okay I was in class when
professor Carl Sagan talked about this
idea of nuclear winter where you'd set
off so many nuclear weapons so rapidly
all the debris thrown in the sky would
make the earth cold and this was
dismissed for a while until Walter and
Luis Alvarez found an impact crater off
Chicxulub Mexico that was almost
certainly where this asteroid hit that
killed the ancient dinosaurs in the same
way by throwing this cloud of debris
that the ejecta the ejected material
from that impact was bigger around than
the diameter of the earth dr. Chad Sahib
so what's concluded about GMOs are they
safe to eat or not yes GMOs are safe to
eat
we feed genetically modified food to
rats
lab rat mice all the time and they're
fine the problem is that what
genetically modified organisms have
enabled monocultures these enormous
fields of the same type of plant and
that has led to some environmental
problems now how do people actually
believe the earth is flat I'm stumped
Kelly I don't know how people believe
that we have classroom globes we have
spacecraft to take pictures you can find
documents from medieval times where
people knew the world was around
Columbus Christopher Columbus knew the
world was round he just sold Queen
Isabella on the on the idea that he
could get it done really fast sailing
around the world Derek why are people
willing to pay more for organic food
when there's absolutely no evidence that
is any better for you perception it's
marketing man people want to feel that
no pesticides were used and they're
thinking maybe globally it's not just a
question of whether or not it's good for
you it's a question of whether or not
it's good for the ecosystem and good for
the agriculture of the sustainability of
our agricultural systems one of these is
organic and one of them is genetically
modified do you know which one neither
do i but generally the bigger one no no
no you can't tell carry on final
question hey Bill are you free for
dinner
often often thanks for your question
carry on thank you all for supporting
science we went through your tweets and
we had nothing but fun time Bill Nye see
you next time